House leadership was able to block
congressman Massey's plans to force that
recorded vote but just the fact that he
floated the plan meant that hundreds of
his colleagues were forced to return to
Washington and many of them from both
sides of the aisle let him know that in
the midst of the Cova 19 situation they
were not happy about that so talking
exclusively to Fox News at night right
now about why he did what he did the
Republican congressman from Kentucky
joins us live congressman Massie good to
have you hey thanks for having me on
Shannon I guess I was able to force him
to come to work but I couldn't force him
to work ultimately they they came to DC
but they decided not to vote on it at
all and that's unfortunate because I
didn't delay the vote at all I think
that's what the president was upset with
he didn't understand the process that I
was proposing you know Tuesday the
Senate was here and they were voting and
the house was the house leadership
Pelosi and McCarthy said you know what
let's just pass this on a unanimous
consent and tell everybody to stay home
don't bother coming to Congress the
problem with that shannon is this is the
third coronavirus bill by the way I
voted for the first one this is the
third one Nancy Pelosi already has a
fourth one planned if you watch the
debate you Democrats we're talking about
what they're going to put in the fourth
bill but you know if we get in this
habit of just passing bills and nobody
even comes to work and they pass that's
really dangerous that's paving the road
for Pelosi okay yeah okay wait but you
know these are unique circumstances and
there were people who thought it was
dangerous to bring everybody back in and
one of them was one of your Republican
colleagues Peter King said this in a
tweet Health House passes pandemic
emergency bill victory for America large
number of Congress members had to be in
the House chamber and risk infection to
themselves and others because of one
arrogant member if anyone gets infected
blood is on Rep Thomas Massey's hands
how do you respond that's a pretty
strong statement I mean here think about
the arrogance of these congressmen
they're telling the truckers to keep
driving so that their grocery stores
will have groceries they're telling the
UPS drivers to keep bringing their
amazon packages they're telling the
bagger at the grocery store to keep
bagging those groceries but these
congressmen make $174,000
a year they've got the best health care
that you can buy these days right now
and they're telling people that they
should that the congressmen need to stay
home but everybody else needs to work
for them
I think that's the wrong message but
that's really gives you a glimpse into
how some of these people in Washington
DC think okay you you've said that you
were concerned what you wanted was a
recorded vote where everybody would have
to say Masey I or know everybody would
have to go through this process the
House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
says there was an appropriate vote here
is his take on this we do have everybody
on the record you know what we were able
to do we didn't pass it with unanimous
consent I would never agree to that but
we were able to have three hours of
debate we had a voice vote for those who
weren't able to make it they could
actually put across the desk
how they would stand on the how they
would stand on the bill okay so there
was some debate there he says he
wouldn't have gone for a unanimous
consent bill so what didn't you get that
you wanted today well first of all they
had four hours of debate and they
couldn't find one minute to allow me to
debate that's because they don't want to
hear the truth that this bill such a
great bill why not have everybody vote
on it now the vote he's talking about
you know writing your name on a slip of
paper that's not showing up and casting
a vote that's going to be recorded for
all time in the congressional record if
you it's so it's not a real vote he was
trying to have a pretend vote to placate
everybody and say that you could stay
home by the way Kevin McCarthy wants to
be the next speaker so he wanted to make
this as easy as he could on everybody he
was trying to be Santa Claus and say you
can stay home and you don't really have
to vote and we'll pretend like we're
voting here and then we'll tell
everybody that's what it is
the problem with Kevin's plan is it
didn't satisfy the Constitution I
literally had to tweak the Constitution
and and shame everybody basically into
acknowledging that if you don't have a
quorum you can't pass a bill in Congress
now to mr. Kings point only half of
Congress had to show up today to pass
this bill and it didn't delay the bill
by even an hour because I told everybody
what my plan was you know a day ago so
that they had time to get he
yeah and many of them were not happy
about that because of the you know
warnings against traveling we had two
more of your members today who announced
that they've tested positive for kovat
19 as well okay listen you earned
yourself the name mister no from
political because Politico because you
do vote no on so many things I know that
you have your reasons and we thank you
for coming on tonight to talk about them
hey Massie thank you thanks for having
me shame